Les filles ont lancé le feu d'artifice avec leur esprit
[musique]
grand-mère du diable grand-mère Vera combien
des cours pour vous
pas grand chose encore
je ne veux pas partir
Je peux vivre encore, je n'irai nulle part
Pourquoi tu ne veux pas y aller ?
[applaudissements]
Bien
[musique]
parce que
pour l'évacuation
les enfants viennent de naître avant-hier, comment vont-ils ?
Je vais les jeter, il faut traire la chèvre, il leur en faut trois
il est temps de donner à boire aux petits. Bon, comment ça va déjà ?
la plaque décide
ou quelqu'un que je ne connais pas, regarde juste
toi, pour ainsi dire, ta vie, ton enfant
et les enfants d'un côté
[musique]
parc
Yarik réussira
persuadez-les
Mais c'est un sourire
hauteur
laser, c'est-à-dire qu'ils voient juste la voiture
et ils lui tirent dessus. Eh bien, parce qu'ils se battent
actions ici, n'importe quelle voiture ici est le but, je suis pour toi
Ce n'est pas qu'ils sont mauvais, mais ceux-là sont bons
alors tout est simple, tout est réel pour toi
Je vais te dire à quoi ça ressemble, eh bien, le voici
nous devons vraiment décider et partir
pire que moi ici, c'est difficile à imaginer
vous pouvez voir les conditions maintenant
pars, comprends que tu le feras déjà
vos enfants seront en sécurité
honnêtement, nous ne laissons personne dans la rue
5000 personnes
[musique]
avec des acheteuses
ils y sont allés deux fois, quelque chose n'allait pas
il s'est avéré que ce n'était pas le bon endroit, j'ai tout pris là-bas
Eh bien, comme d'habitude, c'est plus court
[musique]
aller
solidaire j'ai déjà vécu à Artemovsk je ne veux pas
Je ne vais nulle part maintenant
Certainement
pas d'argent
[musique]
Parle-toi, nous sommes humains
arrivé
Pourquoi vos enfants êtes-vous dans la zone de combat ?
garder l'action
Bien sûr, vous pouvez grimper sur les chiens
mais ils sont liés en principe allez
vos enfants
ok, laissez-nous vous parler
Bien
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Je comprends, je demande juste ce qui devrait
ça arrive alors allons-y
qui devrait rentrer chez lui, pas rester, pas
Que Dieu bénisse tes bras et tes jambes, alors tu iras ici
quel moment attends-tu
[musique]
livrant un tel pliage
Bonjour
[musique]
celui-ci est venu spécialement pour toi
tout le monde monte
[musique]
soigneusement
Pourquoi pas plus tôt
peint, c'était très calme. Eh bien, dans
écouteurs
pas moi, nous ne servons pas, nous sommes des bénévoles
sur la chaîne
3 octobre
[musique]
Bonjour Oui, bonjour, c'est Ignat qui a été emmené
Vos proches peuvent les accompagner
parler
[musique]
Je t'embrasse à plus tard
Je ne peux pas encore dire oui, ils sont avec toi
contacts téléphoniques il y en aura d'autres là-bas
enverra
vos numéros
S'il te plaît
Au revoir
[musique]
Gloire à l'Ukraine
L'Ukraine est devenue pauvre pendant
déçu le bonheur j'espère plus loin
Je serai plus grand et plus beau
[musique]
elle